OIL AND SO MUCH MORE.
MR. VICE-PRESIDENT, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD YOU ARE DOING
A FUNDRAISER FOR THE NEW YORK
GUBERNATORIAL HOPEFUL.
WELCOME TO THIS PART OF AMERICA
WHERE YOU WANT TO GET AWAY FAST
BECAUSE TAXES ARE INSANE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Sean: THESE ARE TROUBLING
TIMES.
LET'S START WITH OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT SAYING THEY
ANTICIPATE THAT A RUSSIAN FULL
ON ATTACK OF UKRAINE IS
IMMINENT, WITHIN ANY HOUR.
IT COULD HAPPEN WITHIN THE NEXT
48 HOURS.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> I MUST TELL YOU THAT TO SEE
THE WAY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS HANDLED UKRAINE IS
A TESTAMENT TO A HISTORIC TRUTH.
WEAKNESS AROUSES EVIL.
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION FROM
VERY EARLY ON APPROVED THE NORD
STREAM-2 PIPELINE, A GIFT TO
RUSSIA.
REOPENED NEGOTIATIONS OVER THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THEN THE DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
I THINK IT CREATED THE
CONDITIONS THAT EMBOLDENED OUR
ADVERSARIES AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING PUTIN AND RUSSIA TO DO
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TODAY.
I MUST TELL YOU THE LACK OF
A STRONG AMERICAN RESPONSE WHICH
WOULD NOT INCLUDE MILITARY
TROOPS BUT WOULD INCLUDE MAKING
SURE UKRAINE HAS THE ABILITY TO
DEFEND ITSELF AND TO SHIP ARMS
AT RECORD PACE AND HAVE PUNITIVE
SANCTIONS BEFORE THE FACT OF
A RUSSIAN INVASION WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEGUN, IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE FACT THAT THE WORLD HAS
JUDGED THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND FOUND
IT WANTING.
NOW MORE THAN EVER, WE NEED TO
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE OF AMERICAN
STRENGTH.
>> Sean: WE SAY THAT, OKAY.
THE TRUMP AND PENCE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT GRANT THE
WAIVER FOR THE PIPELINE.
JOE BIDEN DID GRANT THAT WAIVER.
NOW THEY ANNOUNCED SANCTIONS
AGAINST NORD STREAM-2.
A REVERSAL BACK TO YOUR POLICY.
THERE IS ANOTHER HUGE FACTOR.
ONE OF THE GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF THE TRUMP AND PENCE
ADMINISTRATION WAS FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 75 YEARS AMERICA WAS
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
YOU LEFT OFFICE LEAVING AMERICA
AS AN EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
HOW BIG OF A FACTOR IS THAT IN
THIS?
>> IT WAS NO ACCIDENT THAT
RUSSIA DID NOT ATTEMPT TO REDRAW
TERRITORIAL LINES BY FORCE UNDER
OUR ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: WHY NOT?
>> WELL, IN 2008 WHEN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN OFFICE
THEY WENT INTO GEORGIA AND IN
2014 THEY TOOK CRIMEA WHEN JOE
BIDEN WAS THE VICE-PRESIDENT.
WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO DEFEND
OUR NATION AND TO STAND WITH OUR
ALLIES AROUND THE WORLD.
WE SENT A MESSAGE OF AMERICAN
STRENGTH.
PEACE COMES THROUGH STRENGTH.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT.
WHEN RUSSIAN ALLIES SYRIA USED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ON INNOCENT
CIVILIANS.
THEN WE TOOK DOWN ISIS AND WHAT
RUSSIA SAW, WHAT CHINA SAW UNDER
THE TRUMP AND PENCE
ADMINISTRATION WAS AMERICAN
STRENGTH, A COMMITMENT TO DEFEND
OUR NATION AND A WILLINGNESS TO
USE FORCE TO PROSECUTE OUR
INTEREST AROUND THE WORLD.
I MUST TELL YOU, AGAIN, THAT
COMBINATION OF REOPENING THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL AND
CAPITTULIZATION ON THE NORD
STREAM-2 AGREEMENT, WE PUT THE
SANCTIONS IN PLACE -- BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WE WILL
CALL OUR NATO ALLIES TO LIVE UP
TO OUR COMMITMENTS AND OPPOSE
EFFORTS FOR GERMANY AND EUROPE
TO BECOME DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA
FOR MORE NATURAL GAS.
WE PUT THOSE SANCTION INTO
PLACE.
IT WAS THAT COMMUNICATION OF
AMERICAN STRENGTH THAT HELD
RUSSIA AT BAY.
IT'S BEEN THE SIGNALS OF
WEAKNESS AND MOST ESPECIALLY THE
DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL OF
AFGHANISTAN THAT EMBOLDENED
PUTIN AND THE ONLY RESPONSE IS
AMERICAN STRENGTH.
>> Sean: I IMAGINE PRESIDENT XI
IS WATCHING.
HE SPOKE ABOUT REUNIFICATION
WITH TAIWAN.
HE'S BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE TAKING
OVER TAIWAN AIR SPACE WITH
FIGHTER JET.
CRACKED DOWN IN HONG KONG.
COVID-19, THE WIEGER MINORITIES.
THERE IT HAS BEEN NO SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSE.
IF YOU TOLD JOE BIDEN WHAT WOULD
BE THE POSITION OF STRENGTH AT
THIS MOMENT, WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
ON THE VERGE OF INVADING
UKRAINE, HOW DOES HE STOP IT AT
THIS LATE HOUR?
THE SHIP MAY HAVE SAILED.
>> MY VIEW IS WITH RUSSIAN
MILITARY MET SO-CALLED
SEPARATISTS REGIONS, THEY HAVE
ALREADY INVADED UKRAINE.
>> Sean: AGREED.
>> THE WAY TO STOP THEM AND TO
GET THEM TO WITHDRAW WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ARM UKRAINE.
THEY ARE NOT A NATO ALLY.
WE DON'T HAVE A MUTUAL DEFENSE
OBLIGATION BUT WE OUGHT TO SHIP
MORE ANTI-TANK MISSILE.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
THEY SENT BLANKETS AND MEALS.
WE SENT ARMAMENTS TO UKRAINE SO
THEY COULD DEFEND THEMSELVES.
WE OUGHT TO REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS.
THE INITIAL ROUND OF SANCTIONS,
WEAK AS IT IS, IS NOT ENOUGH TO
STOP PUTIN'S AMBITIONS TO REDRAW
THE LINES IN EUROPE BY FORCE.
WE OUGHT TO SANCTION EVERY
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IN RUSSIA
UNTIL THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
WITHDRAWS FROM THE UKRAINE.
OUR ECONOMY IS 15 TIMES LARGER
THAN RUSSIA'S ECONOMY AM WE ARE
THE MOST POWERFUL ECONOMY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
IMPOSE SANCTIONS ON FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IS TO CUT THEM OUT
OF COMMERCE AROUND THE WORLD.
I BELIEVE WE OUGHT TO PUT STRONG
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS.
WE OUGHT TO BE ARMING UKRAINE IN
A REAL SENSE.
LASTLY, WE OUGHT TO BE MOVING
RESOURCES THROUGH NATO TO
ALLIES.
MY CONCERN -- AS PUTIN MOVES
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE IN UKRAINE
WITH AMBITIONS WELL BEYOND THE
SEPARATISTS AREAS -- IT WON'T
STOP THERE.
>> Sean: YOU THINK THEY WANT THE
WHOLE COUNTRY?
ARE THE BALTIC STATES IN PLAY?
>> IN OUR FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE
RUSSIA WAS AMASSING TRIPS ALONG
EASTERN EUROPE WITH THE LARGEST
MILITARY EXERCISE.
OUR ADMINISTRATION SENT ME THERE
TO FLAG THE FLAG WITH NATO LIES
AND MAKE SURE RUSSIA KNEW WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR
COMMITMENTS.
RUSSIAN AGENTS ATTEMPTED TO
ASSASSINATE A HEAD OF STATE.
THE REALITY IS WE OUGHT TO BE
ARMING UKRAINE.
MAKING SURE THEY CAN DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
WE OUGHT TO BRING ECONOMIC
PRESSURE ON RUSSIA THROUGH THE
STRENGTH OF OUR ECONOMY AND
SANCTIONS.
WE OUGHT TO BE SHORING UP OUR
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE FOR THE
COMMON DEFENSE TO ALL OF OUR
NATO ALLIES.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT
THAT TAIWAN IS NEXT AND CHINA
WILL GO AFTER THEM?
>> SEAN, I WAS JUST ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA AND CHINA SENT
THE SECOND LARGEST AERIAL ARMADA
AGAINST THE TAIWAN STRAITS THAN
EVER BEFORE.
CHINA IS CONTINUING TO ACT IN A
MENACING AND THREATENING WAY
TOWARD TAIWAN.
NORTH KOREA FIRED 7 MISSILE
DURING THE MONTH OF JANUARY
ALONE.
WEAKNESS AROUSES EVIL.
WHETHER IT'S NORTH KOREA BACK TO
FIRING MISSILES OR THE MILITARY
PROVOCATIONS OF CHINA IN THE
TAIWAN STRAITS OR THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA, WHETHER IT WILL BE
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY MOVING INTO
UKRAINE, WE ARE LEARNING ONCE
AGAIN THE LESSON OF HISTORY.
THE FREE WORLD IS SECURE WHEN
AMERICA IS STRONG AND THE WORLD
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE ARE WILLING
TO USE THAT STRENGTH TO DEFEND